if you've seen the rat Queen from
Netflix's Cabinet of Curiosities you'll
probably never forget her here's how the
creative team brought the creature to
life without digital effects Halloween
may have come and gone this year but
Guillermo del Toro's Cabinet of
Curiosities isn't going anywhere you can
still have a spooky good time with it
if you're unfamiliar with the Netflix
series it's an anthology of eight spooky
tales in the vein of Tales from the
Crypt or masters of horror a brief
glance to the cast list proves out while
big celebrity Talent might not show up
for all horror projects everyone shows
up for Del Toro the curiosity is vary
drastically featuring everything from
demonic storage units to alien infested
corpses to ghostly forests to rodents of
unusual size fortunately only one of
those Abominations was brought to life
with only practical effects
unfortunately it was the rats and that
thing is terrifying in the second
episode simply titled graveyard rats at
down on his luck grave robber played by
David Hewlett can't seem to hold on to
any trinkets that he a nurse because an
ungodly swarm of rats statues the
treasures away the moment he finds them
as you can see them are by which end he
can't seem to really take the hint
though and continues to Rob Graves
eventually he stumbles across what the
show's art team casually referred to as
the rat Queen while the term Queen imply
an aura of Grace the rat Queen has none
of that it does have what you might call
some Royal Authority though it's a truly
intimidating creature
she's a monstrous Beast of an
animatronic puppet with bulbous milky
eyes and wispy fur that hardly covers
her mottled skin next to Hugh lets the
rat Queen puppet is more than human size
it's basically the size of a horse
Vincenzo Natalie who directed the
episode told Newsweek that the rat Queen
was something of a miracle even if it
looked like a nightmare he said it is
the first puppet that I've worked with
that actually works 100
it was really quite something to behold
the desire was always to make our
creatures with physical tangible
materials that Sadi went on to describe
all the benefits of sticking with
practical effects because it gave
Hewlett something to act against which
CGI wouldn't do he said the queen rat
was so shocking and they had it right in
David's face I think it was better than
if he was acting to a tennis ball on a
grip stand and it's thrilling there's
something about watching that on a
monitor when everything's actually in
the frame and it's happening in real
time that is exhilarating for everybody
then you get get a subtlety in terms of
how that creature interacts with the
light and even little things like the
way its whiskers move and so on that
would be very difficult to do digitally
a team of spectral motion the company
that created the rat Queen puppet
clearly created something very lifelike
but it can't move on its own at least
not yet but now at least a creature
requires a helping human hand Natalie
said the puppeteers were fantastic and
we had a great time I had a great time
directing the puppet like the puppet is
a character it is an actor on that set
it's kind of thrilling for me as a
director to interact with a creature
like that
at least he was having fun